viens me rejoindre c'est toi qui va
démarrer honneur c'est très simple tu
vas devoir prendre une carte si elle est
inférieur à la mienne tu auras un gage
si elle est supérieure à la mienne on
peut avoir un tu auras
le gars entre toi et moi c'est à l'aide
de post-it numéroté tu vas devoir
classer les chroniqueurs du plus
intelligent au plus bête en leur collant
sur le front
on peut même le faire tout de suite
si je gagne c'est quoi plus petit ou
plus grandes application tu penses que
tu veux
tu peux faire ce que tu veux vas-y moi
j'ai pas vu les cartes
donne-moi ma carte vous déteste
tu attires vers toi non non vas-y montre
ta carte
montre ta carte
[Applaudissements]
la plus grande plus grande merci
donc du plus
intelligents
du plus intelligent plus intelligents
[Applaudissements]
je vois pas d'égalité normal
ma chérie pour un gage le gars il est
très simple celui qui perd devra danser
le reggaeton danser avec son pire ennemi
ah ok d'accord
il va rentrer
[Rires]
ils ont prévu aussi attention tu es
prête voilà la carte que tu veux
la carte que tu veux la plus grande qui
perds
alors
je t'explique d'accord
[Applaudissements]
mais non je pense que tu veux
regarder mais non
[Applaudissements]
personnes
je regarde pas là il y en a qu'une
normalement vas-y non
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci professeur
ma chérie viens me rejoindre le gage
c'est recevoir le bonjour de gens le
poulain Jean le chocolat Poulain ah non
ramenez c'est très simple c'est avec un
pinceau tu fais un beau jour de la peur
bonjour de la pioche bonjour du chocolat
Poulain d'accord le bonjour de la tour
et du chocolat
c'est pour toi merci
[Applaudissements]
attention
j'aime pas le chocolat
c'est très simple tu as ton tel ton
téléphone oui c'est très simple celui
qui perd de nous deux devra faire un tue
la vue mon cul à la personne la plus
importante de ton répertoire
t'inquiète président
tu prends ta carte tu sais ma gueule
[Applaudissements]
et toi
[Rires]
il faut que je réfléchisse
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la photo c'était incroyable
quelqu'un qui est ouvert
tu crées un jeu hyper ok un problème
pour moi la personne la plus importante
de mon répertoire c'est la dernière
personne que j'ai appelé c'est Soraya
Meziane
le Président
vous avez des amis vous avez des amis
je trouve que je trouve un bon truc
voilà je vais dire allez c'est quoi on
va appeler une grosse entreprise
[Musique]
19h15
[Rires]
on s'en fout moi on s'en fou
[Applaudissements]
allez Bernard Isabelle tu as perdu c'est
bon si j'avais perdu allez Bernard il a
perdu
c'est bien c'est bon
tu as perdu
tu as perdu je suis désolé
je suis désolé tu as perdu tu as perdu
moi aussi j'avais perdu je l'aurais fait
accepte de perdre Elsa giberstein
[Musique]
non mais t'inquiète pas
j'en ai plein le patron alors mon patron
appelle taper qui marche pas
un petit peu de caca
ça va mon Stéphane
je suis content on reçoit des gens bien
tu sais Dao lundi tout ça ça va être top
et puis et puis et puis Florent Pagny on
le reçoit jeudi matin je suis très très
heureux de ça tu l'as vu
je suis désolé ça en direct
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tout cas je te remercie ton humour
embrasse bon merci bravo
dis-lui que c'est pas trop dur
aujourd'hui
c'est fait
[Musique]
ça
merci merci Stéphane
[Applaudissements]
les invités
donc là il est 19h20
ça fait 25 minutes qu'on fait des
conneries
ça vous a l'air pas mal
j'aime bien vous perdez vous faites le
truc c'est tout
alors je te jure la vérité et je te jure
que c'est vrai je veux pas dire mais
même en régie tout ils sont outrés je te
jure ça marche toujours c'est vrai tu
abuses